ces is back in las vegas it's one of the
largest conventions in the world and
it's making its in-person return after
going virtual last year because of covet
19 concerns but this year's event is
coming right as those omicron cases are
surging here in the las vegas valley
really all over the country sasha loftus
spoke with convention goers this
afternoon joining us live with what
they're saying about this show
denise and brian you can see people
walking in front of the convention
center here coming in and out of the
doors heading out to ces many we spoke
with said they're really glad to have
this back here in person but it is a lot
smaller than years past
ces 2022 is marking its in-person return
after last year's switch to a virtual
convention but the event comes as
omicron case numbers surge across the
country and thousands of flight
cancellations continue ces attendees
have to show proof of vaccination masks
are required inside and testing is
highly encouraged organizers say 2200
exhibitors are confirmed with tens of
thousands expected to attend those i
spoke with today shared some of the
protocols related to covet as they came
in the quick test kits a couple that we
that we should use ourselves
but i feel very secure in there there's
mask mandate and it's not no problem in
2019 there were 4 400 exhibitors and
about 182 000 attendees ces 2020 was the
last in-person show just weeks before
the shutdown
the ces kicked off today it was set to
run through saturday but as an
additional safety measure will be
wrapping up on friday at 6 pm as you
heard that one man say they are given
tests those rapid tests when they enter
those attendees but it is not required
to test it is just recommended reporting
live tonight sasha loftis live local now